start bench cut eight and Cooper Archie
you're gonna start Archie you're gonna
bench Hayden and cut cover best Trash
Talk you've ever heard
the profession here much trash talk I
heard the opposite like offense linemen
would sweet talk defensive lineman so it
wouldn't play as hard like Richie sorber
was telling Albert Haynesworth like hey
I voted for you in the Pro Bowl you're a
great player so like hopefully you know
he doesn't go as hard the next play
What's the most memorable prank you've
ever played a rookie quarterback who
showed up late to an off-season uh
meeting technically it's voluntary
didn't have to be there I still cleaned
out his locker and put a note pretending
to be coach Coughlin just to look on his
face that he thought he was going to get
cut after being there for a week was
pretty Priceless
bowling just because you know some of
the greatest athletes in the world are
bowlers
teaching like Communications uh I would
teach an online class just about time
management